you can stream on patreon now can't you
what I'm pretty sure you can patreon has
video hosting and streaming now so you
can just yeah you can just like stream
up straight to patreon so if you want to
do a [__] [__] and ball out on Center
stream like go for it how much how much
money would it be worth to us to do a
naked stream
what's my price I'd pay like at least 50
bucks to sit on that
and you gotta have Text-to-Speech so I
can donate and comment on the looks nice
walls nice balls nice balls nice balls
so who's getting your [__] out just an
Aussie pass sign yeah I think so I think
so because Joe when have you got your
[__] out I have never heard any what do
you mean many no I'm wait you guys were
just saying in the bathroom before
seeing each other's balls that's an
awesome that's different that's still
getting your [__] [__] balls out
in front of your friends there's a
massive difference between getting your
balls out in a McDonald's and getting
your balls out in the place where you
are supposed to get your balls out I
think I think as well there might be
like a a Japanese thing to it as well
because like again because we have that
like whole Onsen culture right so we're
already not afraid to like see each
other as a deadly combo it is a deadly
combo so it's like I have the aussieness
I'm not giving a [__] about people
seeing my balls and I have the Japanese
side I'm just getting used to seeing you
I think when I stopped carrying it was
the same thing where I had to get my
balls [__] and balls out in front of
everyone for an extended period of time
I was in LA and we went to a Japanese
spot it's called we Spa right Sports
and all the boys I don't have a Greek
god x a bunch of like old streamers yeah
and we all got our [__] [__] out and
I was just like this is normal now I
don't balls and [__] are just after a
while you just like disconnected
laughing if it wasn't actually like a
mandatory thing you just like turn up
and you just
quits
you walk into the establishment already
with your [__] and balls I was just like
what guys where are your caulking balls
this isn't normal why are you wearing
pants you said you've been to Japan many
times before yeah I used to go
um
once a year I tried to because I had
friends in Korea who uh were in the
military people I met online right they
were they I don't know if you guys
remember my friends or yeah I'm in my
friends I don't know if you guys have
went to Korea I come on the hill with
the where all the army guys stay but if
you're in the Army in Korea if you're an
American they're all American if you're
basically you get like three bedroom
houses that's that it's like so nice so
I'd always go there and like can I stay
in one of your spare rooms for like a
week so I'd go I'd go like Japan Korea
and then fly home maybe stop somewhere
else on the way so every year but I
haven't done it since covered you missed
Japan you said you just got like slept
on a train once and just woke up in a
random yeah well I mean you get the
train passes yeah the JL pass yeah Jr
passes and you should [__] I
I was in an Airbnb and it like ended
because I had always just traveled with
like a backpack and a really small
suitcase right so I hopped on one of the
trains one then I fell asleep not on
purpose I just fell asleep and I woke up
and I was like oh I'm here now and um I
messaged one of my friends and I said
what's there to do here and he was like
well you're like an hour bus ride from a
really cool village with nice scene I
was like all right go go there and then
I'm there I'm like the [__]
um I was really really far west uh
because up the top it snows right yeah
yeah I was really far down West near
like fishing villages so I went to one
oh I went to one of the fishing villages
and I was like what do I do now it's
every village
now and he's like people
fishing so there's a bunch of local guys
there and they like you just walk up to
him he's like yeah just [__]
translate this to them they'll give you
a fishing rod for some money I went
there and fished and that's all I did
for like I just sat there and drank out
of vending machines and fished
that sounds awesome it's actually really
great yeah and um I I caught a bunch of
um
what are the little they look like giant
sardines what are they called trouts
traps that's a traps I caught a bunch of
traps and I was like I don't know how to
[__] like I don't know where a
kitchen is you know I light a fire
cooking yeah and that was like man bro
you eat them there was like two Japanese
guys that were a bit younger and they're
like teenagers that live there obviously
and I think they'll just [__] like
they just sat there and drank all day
too and listen to music oh you're coming
back to our [__] place and we'll cook
another outdoor kitchen yeah
that was great but I didn't know how to
ask them if I could stay there for the
night stand up sleep we could have bust
up that night after they said oh my God
and then um and then yeah I was like uh
you know Jack and Baker's right yeah
yeah he was the one that give me
directions I was like can you translate
this I was just messaging my phone can
you translate this for me please like
and stuff like that yeah um so yeah it
was good and yeah how was it like the
fishing or like it was River fishing um
one time was River fishing and one time
was like it was salt water but it was
like just before the ocean bro you got
like a more legit fishing experience
than we did because we just had like a
company our company outing where we all
went fishing and it was like River
fishing so I'm I was like hype because
I've been sea fishing before like on a
boat and it's just it's it is not a good
experience yeah like fishing on the boat
because like it was it's just so much
more intense like to me fishing is just
like putting the rod out
yeah yeah having a chill beer and just
like chilling out relaxing with the boys
but in sea fishing it's like a it's
actually like gameplay
[Music]
it was the only time I've like been
seasick in my life uh so we go like
River fishing with the company and we're
like great we can go to a river chill
with the boys uh and then so they take
us to the river right and they're like
okay you can start fishing in about 15
minutes and we're like why do we have to
wait 15 minutes and I get like a bucket
out they start chucking fish into the
river to attract more fish no no as like
as like the fish
was empty yeah
they just start chucking fish into the
river they're like all right go catch
them oh now I feel blessed as [__]
because that sounds like [__] you
actually got like the proper experience
I mean it was more of a stroke of luck
like yeah I fell asleep when I got
because the one thing I love about Japan
is I know I'm not going to get killed or
robbed I might I've met people that are
Yakuza before yeah and they're [__]
someone asked I got robbed by one that's
another one
we went up a [__]
blackout drunk yeah
yeah I was like oh yeah it's CAD tattoos
I'm like ah I'm not gonna gamble here
I'm just gonna give him my [__] money
yeah he just like give me your money
yeah you just said give me your money
and I was like I'm not taking this why
did you preface this story by saying I
know I'm not gonna get robbed yeah
I don't think that counts as robbery he
just asked you for your money yeah
that's just yeah that's the transaction
you know but I met some other Yakuza
members and they're like really nice and
they'll like tatted up guys they were
just crazy like crazy that was nice but
I know that no matter where I go I can
find my way home because I got Google
Maps on my phone I know that wherever I
go they'll I'll find a way to eat and
sleep and drink yeah because it just
comes out of a [__] vending machine
most of the time or a 7-Eleven yeah and
I know I just feel I just feel safe
there so when I'm there I like to just
essentially I think the crimes there are
either like absolutely nothing at all or
like the most horrific [__] yeah it's
either zero or 100 yeah yeah for sure
there's so many [__] up crimes that
happens in Japan but most of the time
most of the time it's like most of the
time the police have nothing to do yeah
then you hear about this one murder well
like it's like oh a cat has disappeared
and then the next day it's like uh a
dude jumps in a truck and runs over 17
people it's like it's like whoa all
right chill I just find it weird how uh
in all the uh local like uh
municipalities they have the accident
sign and death sign however they count
the deaths in each area every day like
Road deaths right yeah uh not just Road
death not just general deaths in the
area yeah and I'm like oh that's kind of
morbid it's not a bad ass imagine you're
walking down like Central uh you know
Central London like we've had 15 deaths
today and you're like great great thanks
I guess
yeah what's it's it's funny as well
because sometimes you go to tourist
areas and especially like Kyoto you see
some like weird signs of things that you
shouldn't do which is depressing because
that means someone has done it so you go
to like a car park and there will be
literally signs that says please do not
[__] like just yeah
yeah and I I went to uh hakone the other
day and I saw like the weirdest one
where we were in the toilet and there
was a sign saying please do not like
fish there was a guy with a fish
and just the side says no and I was just
like this is depressing because that
means someone's actually tried and done
that like I I just wanna know I'm trying
to figure out I just want to know what
happened what the what the backstory of
this was well there isn't one of those
Sciences
I feel like I would get thrown in jail
for a couple nights if I did that in
Japan I would I actually no I wouldn't
what get your [__] out I was in a naked
person in Japan I mean I mean there's
public you can definitely get arrested
you could be held for like 20 years Jake
took me to like a sex Street okay it was
a bunch of African dudes of security
guards at like Karachi he took me to
[__] but I want to get a [__] one
of the [__] bars that was also the
same article the red light district yeah
that was the same night we got robbed
because I was blackout drunk I'm like
let's just [__] try this place and
we're getting the elevator and he's like
please give me your money I think it's
cover Couture yeah yeah yeah you went to
a [__] bar yeah it was really funny
80 bucks 30 minutes
was it good
um it wasn't the best I've had but yeah
what exactly is the setup the setup is
like it's like leather couches for one
person and you sit back to back with
another guy on the leather caps on the
other side okay so it's like a big room
that makes couches yeah
and she just sucks your dick in front of
you like yeah and there's maybe a guy it
was pretty empty that night there was a
guy over that side I got so nasty
when I first started seeing stuff from
you the one thing I was kind of shocked
by was how open you were about
prostitution and how you partaked in it
and it's expensive and there's like
testing and it's all like set up
properly and like I'm not against it I'm
so totally not against it and then so
I'm like well if I'm not against it why
don't I try it I have dabbles what are
you okay so there's probably some people
watching this you're probably like oh my
God that's so gross like what would you
would you say to those kind of people
who'd think ah girl bear
like these these people uh
they do regular testing yeah I think
Japan would definitely benefit because
they have so much sex work yeah exactly
and it's so legitimized here and it's
just like you meet this person and some
of the girls that I've paid to sleep
with us like 600 bucks an hour and I'm
like oh you drive a [__] 150 000 car
I can see why because if you just have
you know and they're doing regular
meetings and some girls I met were
telling me like oh I have a regular I
don't even have sex with some
six-year-old guy just paid him to come
to his house for five hours a week and
like rub his back and talk to him
because people because people are lonely
yeah sugar daddies yeah yeah and it's
just like and then she's like on the
side I'll get casual clients and they're
like real picky if you walk in there and
they don't like to look you they'll be
like I ain't serving this guy damn like
I like like I've walked in there before
like from experience
because I've never walked into a place
like drunk or something like that yeah
but I've definitely like met some
friends sat had the same conversation
about having here like yeah I've been
with some like sex workers and like oh
you've convinced me I'd love to try it
I'm like you've had some like now you
have to tell me I'm like I'm gonna take
you there they're going to realize
you've had drinks and then they're
knocking it because they don't drive
people like that they're like it's not
like uh disgusting place it's like
you've had too much drink I I guess when
you can make good money from it you can
also afford to be picky about yeah there
are places that I've been to and it's
like I got a three hour wait for a girl
like you want to put your name down and
wait like well I know there's just for a
Rolex or something
I know there's some places where it's
like you can't even like go in on the
date like you have to like book like
days or like even weeks in advance just
to be like I want to see that girl yeah
that's like the girl she's booked out
because literally some people book the
girls for days like rich people will
just be like hey I want this guy at my
house for two days I it's I know it
sounds crazy because you never thinking
you had I never because I know maybe if
I was really rich but I know I'd never
paid it thousands of dollars I have a
goal giving me attention for a few days
yeah there are people out there that are
like I'm rich I'm single or I'm divorced
I also just like fetishes for everything
possible a lot of people like being
one of my arguments is the economy is
[__] and I have paid upwards of 600
for a day so why not just pass a true
heroes
with the housing crisis is sold
with one goal in mind sex and I'm just
like and it's not guaranteed so why
would I pay for this expensive date when
I can pay for that I mean I I think it's
like just uncomfortable conversation for
a lot of people where they don't yeah
they don't like talking about it because
they don't like the idea of you know
somebody paying for it and right and
they'd rather just be your secret and
run terribly and run by gangs and stuff
yeah but it makes way more sense to have
a more regulated and done safely and All
Above boards it's so well done in this
like country yeah it's ridiculous um
yeah I can tell you a million stories
about like situations I've had that have
been so professional too many stories
I can get laid without it but sometimes
I'm a bit [__] lazy and I do have
disposable income so just pay to win pay
to win
why would I do a free to play game when
I can pay to win you tell me about your
CS go Skins and [__] I'm telling me
about my like CS go [__]
I think I think the thing about Japan is
that you know we have like girls bars
and host bars as well
people you know people are interested in
not just paying for like your service
but just paying for like company oh yeah
someone to feel like people are just
lonely yeah
and like you know talking about like
fetishes there's like a fetish for
there's like a fetish for every bar
Under the Sun that you can think of in
Japan so it's something that people like
don't really talk about but obviously
there's a lot of interest as big as
Japan is obviously so
it's got obviously both ends of that
Spectrum where it's so frowned upon yeah
yeah for like certain stuff so then that
sort of stuff builds under the surface
and shows itself there's so many
different ways yeah exactly it's
actually also isn't the culture there
like working seven days a week as well
so like when you ever have time to
actively look for someone today like no
you're gonna find time off and you're
gonna go spend at those bars yeah yeah
for sure unless it's some like like the
family there is a relationship where
they've really although you start dating
someone at your work yes there's no
shortage of those types of
establishments in Japan like even in
places where they would be like pretty
like I guess like family friendly or
whatever they'll just be there like
massive signs saying you know whatever
you can get it it is kind of crazy how
it's it is illegal but it's still so
easy to find yeah it is not at all like
difficult to get or find you just think
why don't they just regulate this like
but I guess also I think the reason why
they don't regulate is because they
don't want to even admit that it's yeah
yeah it's easy to sweep it under the rug
right yeah and it's like you're sweeping
it under the rug to the point where it's
become this like comical large mounted
[__] thing that everyone gets yeah I
went through it's still like yeah let's
pretend that stuff this is Pub I run to
in um in Yokohama and literally opposite
it is this giant giant flashing neon
sign and it's literally just right next
to train station just saying like 30
minutes 15 000 and it's like this is
yeah yeah I know it's almost a joke like
on the other side of the river yeah it's
almost a joke how comical this is like
considering it's illegal and it's like
it's they've got the brightest sign in
all of Tokyo like just there like it's
so [__] I mean Pachinko polls are the
exact same thing right yeah it's like oh
it's supposed to be a loop around but
for the whole Like anti-gambling rules
that they have there but they're also
the brightest biggest [__] without
you take it the thing to the gold next
door your balls aren't worth anything in
that store but so you take it to another
there's another strawberry yeah yeah
didn't you hit like a mega jackpot on
one of those no it wasn't pachinka it
was like but it was one of those ball
games wasn't it there's a million so
yeah yeah do you know how much points
will work no that's probably nothing but
also like you know gambling's illegal
but horse batting and and Boat Boat
betting is also legal so it's also
really weird when I was there I would
win stuff even in the claw games which
is essentially still gambling yeah and
I'd get my prize and they'd say you can
we buy it back off you I was like you
just give me money for this one yeah go
to this store down the road yeah if you
can't take it in your bag this store
down the road will buy it yeah it's it's
the the loophole around it is I think
the law is that like one established
skill games I think yeah one
establishment isn't allowed to do the
whole entire transaction in the one
building so the Looper hole is that they
just separated into two different
establishes yeah I think at one point it
was literally a different floor like oh
go at one yeah you can sell your prizes
yeah yeah well some people are pretty
good at them just spend all day of
course actually skill games they are
I've done so many videos doing it and
like it you you know sometimes I would
look at a machine I'd be like I'm not
gonna do that because that's I'm gonna
lose money 100 on this one but other
ones I'm like okay this is very
achievable I'm depends on how you do it
going to
staff would always come up and show me
how to yeah and you can it's like you
can ask for help immediately like
obviously it's such a difference
it's like I'm trying to get this plushie
and I put 50 hundred [__] dollars
like yeah I [__] switched the thing
inside that doesn't let you win until
you've had it 99 shots of it oh yeah
like it works on like a faith system
right so you could easily play you
wouldn't even theoretically you could
just not touch it and you could just
stand at it and then just be like excuse
me and they'll come over and help you
because they just trust you that you
you've been playing it and that you need
help yeah obviously if it's stuck in a
corner they'll be like oh okay I can see
that you know you've moved it it's
[__] so let me fix it but okay they
would not do that here they would tell
you to go [__] no in the UK as well
they'd be like what get out
that sounds like a you problem yeah go
to weatherspoons oh that sounds good